right for and left to you're looking at
the first ever gameplay footage of
Sebastian Loeb rally Evo a new racing
sim in development for PlayStation 4
Xbox one and PC it's developed by
Italian studio milestone which is
targeting full at 1080p visuals for the
game across all three systems here you
can see the snowy Sweden racecourse
which is one of eight different rally
locations which together offer 64 tracks
in total much like the many racing Sims
of its kind rally Evo tries to
faithfully represent the sport in terms
of looks and physics the game builds
you're looking at as a result of one
year development and it was described to
us as pre-alpha some of the
imperfections you might spot such as the
draw distance bugs should be fixed by
the time the game ships milestone is
hoping to release rally Evo by autumn
2015 that doesn't give the studio much
time to build and polish the game but
milestone nevertheless promises 300
kilometers of track to race on with each
different location of bring several
possible weather effects and light
conditions based on the season and to
find a day but how will this game stand
out in a crowded market well milestone
is betting the farm on Sebastian Loeb
himself who is the legend in the world
of rally right now having won pretty
much everything this sport has on offer
he's their rally equivalent of Michael
Schumacher or LeBron James Lynaugh Messi
Bruce Lee John Cena you get the idea
blurp offers his face and voice to the
game and is also a playable character
this version you're seeing is running on
the PlayStation 4 which much like the
Xbox one edition renders at 30 frames
per second milestone said blocking the
console build to 30 frames per second
offered far more stability than
attempting 60 and allowed the studio to
focus on other graphical factors card
damage modeling and online gameplay
features are also in development though
this will be revealed at a later date
for more details on rally Evo in the
future stay tuned to games box
[Music]